we go
[Applause]
here I am happy Tuesday everybody I love
you keep your shirt on lady
tonight's monologue is for the children
and not just Alec Baldwins
I mean all American kids being destroyed
by people who claim to be looking out
for them I call it
Everybody Run
it's the attack on brats why are the
Democrats so evil
[Laughter]
you know sometimes I think he takes my
direction too literally
I said you know it's about attacking
children and because the attack on brats
it's like a 1950s horror movie about
sausage
tonight I dedicate my monologue to the
Next Generation because someone's got to
look out for them the Democrats
certainly aren't fact is we're in a
culture War and the kids are caught in
the crossfire literally if they're in
Chicago or Baltimore or DC if the mayor
has a d after their name it stands for
duck
post post covid there's a new pandemic
out there it's kids killing kids
according to the Wall Street Journal
violence among kids has soared since
2020 it's a stain on this country
spreading faster than the one on Joe
Biden's pants
homicides by juveniles acting alone Rose
30 in 2020 from a year earlier while
those committed by multiple kids were up
66 and murders committed by kids under
14 are the highest in 20 years
I guess Fox News weatherman Adam klotz
should count himself lucky that he only
got his ass kicked
sure
still though by a group of teens I mean
anyway now police prosecutors and
Community groups point to the lockdowns
deprived children of interaction with
others of course for forcing them to
stay locked out at home their mental
health no doubt will take a hit kids had
to live like prison inmates except
inmates aren't melting their brains with
social media they're too busy sending
fan mail to cat
[Laughter]
she keeps them and when kids aren't
killing each other with guns they're
dying from drugs this is upbeat I'm
telling you fentanyl deaths among kids
are rising faster than the average
parents blood pressure in fact fentanyl
deaths for kids 14 and under have more
than tripled in just two years of course
we know where fentanyl comes from China
just like another poison Tick Tock that
Relentless faucet of brainwash flowing
to every kid's room imagine a device of
self-destruction delivered into every
American Home a device that dares you to
choke yourself to death to swallow
inedible objects to embrace ideas that
alienate you from your family that's
Tick Tock no wonder kids are turning to
prescription and illegal drugs they're
also getting fatter thanks to a diet of
corn syrup and sugar and of course
they're choosing porn over real life so
you got diet drugs education isolation
anti-social Behavior what are these kids
going to be like in 10 years let's hope
let's hope not
and meanwhile there's antifa they seem
fine right they aren't quite kids
anymore but they're young losers with
nothing but hate in their eyes
take a look at the recent arrests from
the Atlanta antifa mostly peaceful
protests
all smug messy-haired rich white liberal
kids who clearly aren't spending their
trust funds on hygiene products
be glad that their mug shots aren't
scratch and sniff foreign
think of Sam bankman with a chip on his
shoulder bigger than his
so what happened
and again where are the adults well Bill
Maher is one adult he's looking at
what's happening to kids and he's
worried too listen to him
we live in a prison yard this country
which is everything is tribal and like
anything to do with schools or education
is something really the Democrats have
to answer for because they control it I
mean if you look at the Democratic
Convention it's like three quarters of
them are teachers my sister's a teacher
I'm a big defender of teachers but
what's going on in schools it's
outrageous and somebody needs to answer
for it now Mar who like me doesn't have
any brats of his own is also saying kids
are being screwed by teachers and not
the fun kind like in the gym teacher's
van
yeah
those were the days he realizes it's not
progress to eliminate rationality
science and Truth unless your end goal
is to screw up the society Beyond repair
you've got events like queer prom at
Bucks County PA with a Democrat state
senator actually bragging about it there
were more there were drag queens with
lube and condoms kids as young as 13
were given dental dams and I still don't
know what that is
and I don't want to know when I was that
age I'd be lucky if I got a stick of
Wintergreen gum
you could do a lot with that
bring this up however and you know what
you get you get the smirk the dismissal
what I call the straw trans argument
it's like a straw man argument but with
boobs and a bulge
if you support Science Biology and a
fundamental truths about life that have
been agreed upon for Millennia now you
hate trans people when in fact it has
nothing to do with trans adults at all
it's about protecting kids from the hard
left who are using kids as cannon fodder
in a culture war and so the kids have
been drafted through lockdowns gender
Warfare hyperbole about the climate
screeds against the country coming from
the classrooms for the left it's all
about power and seizing that power
starts with children it's a mental
version of pedophilia but here it's the
mind they're screwing
let's welcome
tonight's guest
he saved the government Millions by
cutting his own hair on throughout the
new book start Stay or Leave Trey Gowdy
[Applause]
he's got the Heart of a Lion and the
eyes of a guy that drinks beer for
breakfast actor and comedian Jim Brewer
she's like an elevator if something in
her snaps people die both Zeus
contribute her cat Tim
all right here's I don't know about this
one he's like a laundry basket because
when men see him they throw in the towel
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Trey congrats on the new book I know
it's gonna go number one start Stay or
Leave it's a question in my mind every
Saturday night
I don't know what that means
but uh I bet I I went through a Litany
of problems for kids these days am I
overlooking the resiliency of them like
is this like we all we thought we had it
bad but aren't they feel like they're
having it worse
I I think they have it worse because we
use children and and education is kind
of a proxy war uh for adult Wars and uh
whether some people would argue we've
used the military for that in the past I
think we're using education what struck
me during your monologue Greg is we're
not doing well on reading and writing
the things that we fundamentally or or
frankly teaching children how to think
critically
if we can master that then maybe you
want to take on more complicated things
but we haven't mastered that
it's a devaluing of life you know I was
a prosecutor before Congress but also
part of the other message what you hear
from Progressive prosecutors is that
there's not going to be any consequence
I mean
there was one week Greg where there were
four 17 year olds that went to prison
for life without parole for 17 year olds
which means four people lost their lives
four mothers are saying goodbye to their
kids for life or lost their it's just I
don't know young people sometimes don't
value life the finality of taking a life
and
um yeah I'm glad I'm not growing up uh
primarily because they're cell phones
now and other recording devices but I'm
glad I'm not growing up like they're
growing up well that was an upbeat
response to my questions right
looking at my wrists right now going
tell my wife to get that bathtub warmed
up
Jim you have kids do you ever sometimes
stay up at night wonder if they might
murder you in your sleep
don't worry about that I
I'm more worried about once a while my
kids bring someone home they're like hey
that's they it or was
and I go I swear what is going on
what is your name I don't have a name
what are we playing right now how do we
what are we doing that and then I'm the
jerk yes I'm the maniac
my day woke was cold crazy yeah yes yes
if an eight-year-old came up to me and
said hey man I'm woke I think I'm a girl
I go no you're crazy
let's talk you know that there's now a
thing called trans age have you heard
about this no these are adults who
identify as children and they want you
to look at them as that being their
correct age which then opens the door
for God knows what that's crazy
older if I say I identify as 25 I can
maybe get insurance to pay for my
facelift
see there is a silver lining yeah I'm
always looking for it I'm such a
positive person yeah when you um I was
very I guess I was shocked by the murder
statistic but then I'm wondering like
are they are this all gang stuff like as
a child do they is they call a 17 year
old a child is that fair I don't know
what do you say cat what's your solution
well I believe that children are the
future wow good for you so we should
teach them well and let them lead the
way I just came up with that yeah
yeah
and you know who wrote that
Michael Jackson yeah he loved children
anyway
I'm I'm against murder for people of any
age good for you uh other stuff like you
know in this story I mean that that
promptly was paid for by Planned
Parenthood does that mean our tax
dollars are buying lube for kids yeah
isn't that crazy I'm against that yeah I
think that there's better things we can
spend our money and the bar is so low
now where I think when parents no matter
what your views are when you're talking
about what you know what I what I want
that's best for my kids and the
government has the attitude of don't you
mean our kids right I mean not everybody
wants to be in a throuple with the state
yeah that most people don't yeah and uh
we should start that's there was a lot
there was a lot of that mentality in the
last election where people were saying
that the that the unions the teachers
have more say over kids than the parents
do where are the parents though Tyrus
yeah that's that's a great question
because I think that's the ones who are
involved because you know to answer the
question
um my kids could try to kill me
[Laughter]
they still have a hard time getting past
the look yeah so I don't you know
so uh what if they ganged up on you
they'd still be outnumbered out class
and outside yeah and I know what each
one of them would turn on each other
like that so it's not that hard to talk
one out of it you know you were always
my favorite and then you know they just
that's why you have numbers they'll turn
the eight-year-old will turn on
everybody so and she's my spy so if any
plotting's going on I'll get a text so
you know and then I shoot it down but
but I am responsible for my children so
if my child went out and did something
horrific I'm responsible for that so I
think what needs we I know in Louisiana
we do this a little bit but we got to
start going back to and I hate to say it
you got to have curfews and when
children are charged mom and dad got to
be charged if your kids out running the
street and commits a heinous crime
you're responsible we have to put
responsibility back in the parents now
it used to be it takes a village to run
you know to raise a child but they
didn't mean the Village People you know
what I'm saying like they didn't they
meant a village
naughty
you know and we have to if mom and my if
one of my children ends up being gay or
non-binary or whatever they still have
the same rules as my heterosexual child
yeah so there will be no Loop you know
what there will be no condoms yeah or
there will be murder yeah like you can
be those things without it being
sexualized and that's the that's the
problem that we're that sliding and
trying to slide by us is because what it
is is it's pedophilia you know because
there is no re if you had strippers at
my 13 year old birthday party although I
would say this is the greatest party of
my life and then at some point condoms
will be throwing out I'd be like Mom I
love you so much
that never happened because it'd be
inappropriate and that stripper would be
arrested yeah there's no difference
those are the good old days
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else